Hallo Deutschschule. Zusammengesetzte Nomen.
Fuß + Ball =
der Fußball
Ich spiele Fußball.
Ich renne mit dem Fußball über den Fußballplatz.
Lippen + Stift =
der Lippenstift
Der Lippenstift ist ein Stift für die Lippen.
Sie benutzt den roten Lippenstift.
Regen + Schirm =
der Regenschirm
Der Regenschirm schützt vor Regen.
Wenn es regnet, nehme ich meinen Regenschirm.
Hand + Tasche =
die Handtasche
Die Handtasche ist rot.
Jede Frau braucht mindestens eine gute Handtasche.
Was ist in deiner Handtasche?
Sonne + Brille =
die Sonnenbrille
Ich trage eine Sonnenbrille.
Wie findest du meine neue Sonnenbrille?
Eis + Bär =
der Eisbär
Der Eisbär lebt in der Antarktis.
Erdbeere + Torte =
die Erdbeertorte
Heute backe ich eine leckere Erdbeertorte.
Buch + Regal =
das Bücherregal
Das Bücherregal ist ein Regal für Bücher.
Was ist dein Lieblingsbuch?
Hand + Schuh =
der Handschuh
die Winterhandschuhe
der Putzhandschuh
der Boxhandschuh
der Baseballhandschuh
Beim Skifahren trage ich Skihandschuhe.
Beim Boxen trage ich Boxhandschuhe.
Beim Putzen trage ich Putzhandschuhe.
Eis + Würfel =
die Eiswürfel
Die Cola mit Eiswürfeln.
Soll ich eine Ice Bucket Challenge machen?
Okay, jetzt wirds kalt!
Ohr + Ring =
der Ohrring, die Ohrringe
Es gibt Ohrringe in gold und silber.
Was findest du besser? Gold oder Silber?
Spiegel + Ei =
das Spiegelei
Das Spiegelei in der Pfanne braten.
Zum Frühstück esse ich ein leckeres Spiegelei.
Polizei + Auto =
das Polizeiauto
Das Polizeiauto hat Blaulicht.
Die Polizei fährt mit dem Polizeiauto.
Die Feuerwehr fährt mit dem Feuerwehrauto.
Hals + Kette =
die Halskette
Die Frau trägt eine schöne Halskette.
Eine Halskette mit Perlen ist eine Perlenkette.
Apfel + Baum =
der Apfelbaum
Die Äpfel hängen an dem Apfelbaum.
Yoga + Lehrer =
der Yogalehrer, die Yogalehrerin
Ich lerne Yoga mit einem Yogalehrer.
Papier + Flugzeug =
das Papierflugzeug
Ich baue heute eine Papierflugzeug im Büro.
Rock + Musik =
die Rockmusik
Ich liebe Rockmusik.
Die Band macht richtig coole Rockmusik.
Salz + Wasser =
das Salzwasser
In einem Ozean ist das Wasser
salzig, deshalb sagt man Salzwasser.
Die Salzwasserfische leben im Salzwasser.
Brief + Tasche =
die Brieftasche
Die Brieftasche ist ein altes
deutsches Wort für das Portmonee.
Ursprünglich war es eine Tasche
für Briefe, deshalb Brieftasche.
Wo ist bloß meine Brieftasche geblieben?
Hund + Baby =
das Hundebaby
Hundebabys sind so süß.
Telefon + Buch =
das Telefonbuch
In einem Telefonbuch stehen viele Telefonnummern.
In Deutschland gibt es in jeder
Stadt ein offizielles Telefonbuch.
Holz + Tisch =
der Holztisch
Der Holztisch ist aus Holz.
Ich arbeite an einem Holztisch.
Arbeitest du auch an einem Holztisch?
Abonniere jetzt den Kanal der HalloDeutschule
und aktiviere das kleine
Glöckchen.
Gib uns jetzt einen Daumennach oben
und klicke auf diese Playlist
für weitere Videos zum Deutsch lernen.